to me forever
[Music]
you know what Don of me recently no what
we're done on you recently I know you
didn't know yeah exactly because I
wasn't there when it dawned on you
exactly my brain okay
I don't know if I would have gone here
if I didn't do this job
but I think as a result of doing this
job you've gotten here I'm sorry carry
on
yes technically true just just scary on
my bed I don't think my entire life I've
ever been
in close proximity with family
no you're never 16 I already moved out
was had a job during the military
traveling doing work gigs in different
cities I was never around
never bothered because I'm like yo
obviously not oftentimes as a kid like
it's rare that we had family dinners
it's rare that we all sat down and ate
together or we went out and did
vacations it's just I didn't think it
was a problem because that was my normal
so I'm like oh
some families just built different it is
what it is yeah and then what happened
okay so thanks to this YouTube [__]
right like folks see me we've been in
the same Studio this whole time people
think it's a gimmick or whatever no I
actually live here this is like my
little room it's been my room for eight
years I've not moved out of this
apartment I could get a spot I just
don't because I'm happy here but thanks
to some of the disposable income I've
had if it ain't going to like
initiatives I have I've been able to
like help my mom out with certain things
and one of the things I decided to do as
my mom getting older you know as people
around us get older you want to take
care of them so I moved my mom five
minute walk away bit of an expensive
spot not a whole lot even though my
apartment's like a thousand dollars a
month for a three bedroom hers is a lot
more expensive you went in I got her a
nice condo she did a good job you know I
mean she walked in she said I'm gonna
Spruce this [__] up it'll look kind of
cool I'll show you some pictures so
first stop thank you guys okay because
because of you I got them closer but
something hit me the other day my mom
just knocked down my door she just
rolled through because she live five
minutes away she just knocks sometimes
and I'm like what you doing she's like
oh just chill
oh my god let's go chill my living room
we said that we had a conversation
and that happened two three times in the
week you know we'd have dinner together
or we'd chit chat or whatever it might
be
I was just like oh this is what family's
like hmm this is what it's like when you
have people in close my presidency that
you can count on to regularly for this
or little things like that yeah or
you can just spend time with or you you
just leisurely like it's not an event
it's not Christmas it's not we just see
each other yeah
um
we hang out
do you know how weird it is to be 33
years old and think like starting things
and then it's like this is my first time
I hung out with my mom before I used to
be like hey there's dinner come grab
some food and I'd go grab my plate and I
would go or whatever it might be this is
the first time you just take a walk
together we sat at a cafe and we just
looked outside ain't it nice huh oh so
funny what you like doing because she's
trying to discover the city homegirl
gets on the bus and just rides it I am
mad at that she hasn't and she looks
outside the window she likes looking
down and she takes long walks she has
time now I'm like actually she relaxed
and uh and then it's just
as she should I don't know if it's sad I
don't know if I should be glad I'm glad
because you're better late than never
but I don't know
33 wait wait wait wait wait yeah go
ahead
because I don't understand how you feel
like at 33 Okay okay I don't look at it
as
[__] it should have happened before but
hey what is done is done yeah you can
never [__] go back
yeah it's done
but be glad that it happened
some [__] will never experience
that
effort so you're half full not half
empty no I got water
yeah I'm not saying have have nothing
but I'm not thirsty I'm not thirsty yeah
okay I'm not gonna be drinking yeah
but I didn't know I didn't know I
thought it was so delicious because my
lips were tapsed I didn't know I saw big
titties and I got excited I didn't know
but
[Music]
and now at 33 yeah you can always serve
yourself again
true some people will never drink that
water sure because some [__] happening
in life happened and then boom they
never see these people ever again now
your thing is you have to enjoy all
those moments because let's be real
about some [__]
like they saying good kid be quiet
which means there's less there's less
time left than there was before so yeah
that's that's that sounds sad too
but I got time
and enjoy it yeah you're right you
understand what I'm saying is it sad I
can't change it yeah
[__] sad I can't change that I don't
have the power but I would say this go
ahead most people watching would think
maybe I'm wrong most people think you
should have family
when's the last time you really cared
about that
if you
you it's more complicated than that
before I had the relationship that I
have with my parents I had to break away
I had to stop talking to them for a good
two years a lot of things could have
happened in those two years and you know
what I took full responsibility of that
I was hurt I needed to heal I came back
I was lucky enough that by the time I
healed I was able to come back to my
parents came back everything was good I
was one of the lucky ones so I came back
and I I try to build the relationships
like it is now like I've seen my parents
go through some [__]
I've seen my parents go through some
[__] it was really hard we we went you
know we went through that [__] that was
a better thing
you know my dad having cancer my mom
having cancer we went through that now
they heal they all right now we're gonna
enjoy sometimes
something that happened
I just go and pick up my dad and tell
him yo we have to fix the apartment at
the other block yeah cool I'm gonna go
with you and we spend the whole day
together yeah just talking not being
interrupted just the boys and sometimes
I chill with my mom I go home and then
we talk or she come home and we talk
about different things and then we we
talk yeah it's it's
yeah it's yeah okay it's sad that didn't
happen before boo who [__] who
there's nothing you could do about that
move the [__] on
and enjoyed our water cheers
facts
facts I should have brought my pipe away
this in the car
and on that note guys
you're really going to get that pipe
yeah but now that I got a bit of time I
could really say thank you guys thank
you I know I said it before but as I'm
like entering this age and really
settling in and relaxing and just living
life very differently a Time life is
like luxury obviously it's a luxury to
be able to put my mom in the spot that's
that's dope that's dope I mean like my
personal life not luxury big thank you
okay
here you go
and remember kid
stay hydrated
yeah yeah
and you know in light of all this we
going on tour we coming to cities near
you we want to see you [__]
face to face where you at we gonna be
doing shows all summer well this summer
we're doing three shows we're doing
Detroit Pittsburgh and Washington DC but
afterwards we were going to England
we're going to be going all across
America Asia so if you want to get
tickets make sure you guys go to the
website all right put your name so we
can email you as soon as those tickets
come out for your area we won't bombard
you with nothing else okay I promise
yeah
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna do
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys all right I
just want to say thank you honestly uh I
don't know if I would have gotten here
without this maybe I would have still
but regardless it's thanks to y'all
thanks to preach thanks a lot of this
influence and growth that I think I've
been able to go into this next chapter
of my life so yeah thank you
how I made it the fact is I made it and
it's with y'all so I'm appreciative so I
better catch you guys at some live shows
all right
um but yeah the whole family topic is an
interesting one because it takes on you
meeting and I think it's dope that even
at 33 and I'm gonna get older and it's
always going to be humbling experiences
like this and so
yeah if you would have asked me years
ago would I ever think I had this kind
of relationship with my family no
I probably would have tell you I don't
even know why it's important like why
does it matter but now that I got it
it's a bit different
it's a bit different it's just it's like
never seeing colored and seeing color
all of a sudden and it's funny because
you can't explain that this is one thing
is that you told you told me about
family situation stuff like that and I
could have went oh you got to do this I
went
okay because I was not living what the
hell you was living right I didn't live
none of that so it's easy for me to say
like it's important you haven't lived
that yeah I haven't lived with terminals
I haven't gone I was like I just asked
one question you don't know all right no
cool and it never bothered me
and it's okay yeah it never bothered me
because I didn't know there's anything
to be bothered about
and then focused with strong time yeah
it's fine yeah but it's interesting I
just had that epiphanies I want to share
that with you guys but let me know what
you guys see in the comments we want to
hear from you and yes go the website's
below get your tickets all right
okay